le soleil se couche sur la plage c'est
l'heure de l'apéro à tijuana où les
habitants se donnent rendez-vous dans
les bars de la plage pour prendre un
verre
à quelques centaines de mètres de là la
troupe de tête de la caravane a posé ses
valises littéralement au pied de
l'immense barrière qui sépare le mexique
des états unis walter castro est arrivé
il y à quelques heures avec sa femme et
ses deux enfants de robert je respecte
les autorités des états unis et dieu va
intervenir pour qu'il trempe ouvre son
coeur dit il pour tous les migrants à
qui nous avons parlé nous ont dit que
l'idée c'est d'attendre que tout le
monde arrive ici est de traverser
légalement en groupe et quand m or ce
groupe réunit ça veut dire au moins de 7
à 8000 personnes ici la zone nord de
tijuana est un quartier fort difficile
nous dit cet ancien champion du monde de
boxe dont les entraînements dans le
stade ont été annulés car c'est ici en
plein coeur de ce qu'on appelle la zone
rouge ou encore la légende noire que
tijuana planifient des bergers la
caravane tijuana est une ville violente
2000 personnes sont mortes assassinées
depuis le début de l'année 2018
le custom est fait des ravages chez les
voisins de ce camp de réfugiés que yo
que pour l'euro raul perez ne comprends
pas
quelle idée stupide de venir installer
des gens vulnérables dans ce quartier
sittine
le rêve de cette caravane est donc
acculée au pied d'un mur d'une réalité
brutale alors emilie depuis quelques
heures on comprend que tout se complique
et le plus marquant c'est la fin ces
gens enfin et c'est extrêmement
difficile surtout pour ceux qui ont des
enfants écouter les gens sont arrivés au
compte-gouttes cet après-midi par
autobus et quand il débarquait il nous
demandait de l'eau il lui demandait de
la nourriture ils nous ont dit ne pas
avoir mangé pendant deux jours céline on
leur a donné de l'eau sur le chemin mais
il n'avait pas mangé les gens étaient
très très faibles se mettait à pleurer
subitement on a assisté à des scènes
absolument déchirant il ya des
organisations catholiques qui sont venus
distribuer du pain par exemple une foule
qui s'est lancé littéralement sur ses
morceaux de pain en criant un peu plus
tôt quand les premiers repas sont
arrivés des bénévoles sont à portée des
repas chauds les gens crier laisser
manger les enfants laisser manger les
enfants en premier donc c'est assez
chaotique je vous dirai donc 5000
personnes sont arrivées ce matin on les
installe et vous l'avez entendu dans le
reportage dans un stade situé dans la
zone nord de tijuana une zone
extrêmement violente à un coin de rue du
sila commence le territoire des cartel
de tijuana la vente de drogue de drogues
dures il ya beaucoup de gens ici qui
souffre d'une addiction au cristal m et
il ya tellement monde dans le stade et
c'est tellement chaotique que les gens
commençaient à s'installer détente un
peu partout des abris de fortune avec
des toiles cirées
on voit des matelas partout sur les
trottoirs
il ya des enfants qui vont dormir ici
dans ce quartier si de l'âge de la zone
nord qu'on appelle à tijuana la ligue en
dan
la légende noire c'est vraiment un
quartier où on a de la difficulté à
imaginer que des enfants vont passer la
nuit ici au coeur de cette zone
extrêmement dangereuse où je vous le
rappelle je vous en parlais dans le
reportage a eu 2000 mètres cette année à
tijuana
c'est vraiment pas l'idéal donc 5000
personnes sont arrivées aujourd'hui les
autorités
ouanna en attend 4000 autres dans les
prochaines heures
la situation est qualifiée d' urgence
par l'état de la base quelques chauny
qui réclame une aide du gouvernement
fédéral pour faire face à la la la
question à la situation
c'est vraiment désolant mais maintenant
qu'ils sont rendus assez près du but
comment ça va se passer est ce que est
ce que leurs plans se précisent un peu
non s'exclamant c'est vraiment difficile
à dire qu'est ce qui va se passer ces
lignes le plan d'époque laddh pouvons le
demander à plusieurs migrants
aujourd'hui maintenant vous commencé à
arriver est ce qu'il ya plein de matches
d'établi alors la première chose c'est
qu'ils veulent que tout le monde soit
bien arriver à tijuana et la reid est en
fait leur rêve c'est qu'ils vont tous
traversé à la frontière ensemble essayer
de passer légalement aux états unis
ils ont pas beaucoup d'idées précises en
fait de comment ils vont atteindre ce
passage pas d'idée vraiment précise de
comment ça fonctionne
immigré aux états unis mais ils sont
littéralement celle il ya les camps de
réfugiés les cartels et il ya le mur au
coin de la rue le y sont au pied du mur
mais ils ne mesurent pas je crois et
c'est ce qu'on sent dans nos
conversations la mesure pas la réalité
qu'est ce que ça veut dire d'immigrés de
passer ses murs et ne comprennent pas il
fait plus que le contexte politique
américaine ça risque d'être extrêmement
difficile en fait pour eux les
prochaines heures
merci beaucoup emilie